tous ces tous ces sujets en fait pour
nous
relèvent plutôt de l'appréciatif c'est à
dire que nous on présentait un certain
nombre de de
format on les présenter avant même et
le fait qu'on nous dise on aime on
n'aime pas ok on l'entendait mais
c'était pas
c'était pas pour nous
[Musique]
pour nous c'était hors champ du du
contrat qui nous liait donc on
l'entendait parce que bien sûr il faut
préserver une relation avec avec notre
partenaire surtout si on avait dans
l'idée de poursuivre
donc voilà mais mais foncièrement nous
on a toujours tenu à notre liberté
éditoriale
dans le respect dans le respect de la
loi évidemment et le cipdr
[Musique]
nous a à l'occasion
d'un ou deux points
signifier que il y avait une blague anti
Macron qui qui les a pas franchement
fait rire et qui on a eu un échange tout
à fait normal et bienvenu sur le fait
que
on est dans une période sensible qui est
la période des lectorales et que donc si
on doit traiter de sujets politiques
voilà il faut faire un peu attention
mais ça on l'avait déjà intégré pour
nous c'était évident mais
on ne pouvait pas ne pas parler de
sujets politiques on ne pouvait pas le
faire dans une émission d'un
fauteuilment qui
se lance dans cette période enfin
particulière toute l'attention
médiatique tout tout le traitement
médiatique de la question politique
entre janvier et juin été tourné autour
des enjeux de la présidentielle donc on
s'était dit que c'était important de les
traiter et de de
de laisser les chroniqueurs s'exprimer
néanmoins je tiens à le rappeler et par
rapport à la période stricte de la
campagne on a publié aucun compte aucun
contenu à caractère politique et
c'est remarques du cipdr donc qui ont
été faites une ou deux fois n'ont jamais
été
véritablement un point à l'ordre du jour
de nos réunions
qui n'ont déjà jamais fait l'objet d'un
courrier d'un
je peux vous assurer monsieur le
Président c'est que si j'avais un début
de phrase dans un mail qui parlait de ça
mais on aurait réagi immédiatement alors
je ne dis pas comment on aurait réagi on
aurait pris un arbitrage en interne en
disant Stop ou Encore stop on veut
garder notre ADN tant pis pour les
financements ou non non on veut tenir ce
financement et voilà il faut il faut
faire des compromis on aurait pris un
arbitrage mais on l'aurait pris
immédiatement et on l'aurait signifié
immédiatement et et on avait je peux le
dire aussi on n'avait pas on n'avait pas
peur d'aller au contentieux parce que on
remplissait toutes les obligations de de
notre contrat